it's great to welcome back to the show
today bill scher senior writer at
campaign for america's future
contributing editor at Politico bill
last time you were on I believe it was I
don't know a month and a half or two
months ago I suggested that I was
finding this election to be the most
unusual and compelling in a very very
long time and at the time you said well
you know I'm still finding 2008 more
compelling are you now ready to say that
this has gone above and beyond and has
become a very very bizarre and unusual
election well this is the bigger
trainwreck of course but uh and it's it
me Donald Trump has an obsession with
being in the news regardless of whether
it makes sense politically or not so it
always makes it more uh entertaining and
shocking uh but we may be coming up to a
point where the outcome is is known and
we're gonna be lacking a lot of drama uh
for the for the fall campaign which were
not accustomed to where were in the last
couple time adobada was ahead of mccain
by a decent amount there was this
lingering fear that there was a secret
white vote that would materialize that
dough would not uh not uh uh except that
after american president that proved not
to be true uh where's now if if the
polls are six to ten points for for
clinton nationally that there there's no
secret vote that's going to overcome
that on election day yet there's been a
lot of reaction to when I just you know
I don't do polling I know that that
might not be a surprise to you but
seemingly our audience thinks that when
I talk about a poll Ivan some some
weight done the poll in presenting the
numbers I want I've been just reporting
that you know 16 of the last 60 national
polls have Hillary Clinton ahead
etcetera etcetera and some of the
reaction is that for some reason the
polls right now cannot be trusted either
due to over sampling of Democrats which
has been a sort of explained by five
thirty eight pretty precisely as to why
that's not a fair critique of many of
these polls or because they're they're
not yet considering something as you're
talking about some x factor that is not
yet built in there historically speaking
mid-august
you poles start to paint a relatively
precise picture of where the race really
is more people are interested a higher
share of those who will vote are now
paying attention uh mid-august is maybe
a touch early to draw to a precise a
conclusion now we're we are past both
conventions there are some years where
the conventions happen later than mid
August or there have been around
mid-august I just did a piece of real
clear politics lying about Trump's a
theoretical ceiling you go back 12
months with Donald Trump and he has been
between 38 and forty-four percent in the
Real Clear Politics average that's
different than the Republican primary
people talked about a trump ceiling very
arbitrarily and they weren't paying
attention to the fact that the in the
average number was going up up up up uh
the whole time hehe led the the realtor
Paula's average the entire time not the
case versus versus Hillary uh so at
minimum you have to say what Trump has
been doing to this point is not working
now there are there examples where
people pick up steam in the fall Gerald
Ford did Mitt Romney did Al Gore did uh
but something changed something changed
in the in the dynamic of the race for
that to occur uh you know maybe Donald
Trump does doesn't Mitt Romney
etch-a-sketch and read the complete
different character beginning from the
first debate if that happened maybe
those numbers would change I i have not
expecting that and even if he did try it
it's possible that his perception on the
American electorate has been so seared
in that is too late to do a real change
there have been uh some reacting to news
of former and current Republicans saying
not only will they not be voting for
Donald Trump in November some saying
that they will be voting for Hillary
Clinton in November but the reaction has
sort of been along two camps there are
those who email me and say that's
because of the unique disaster
sir that is Donald Trump there are
others who say that's because Hillary
Clinton is such a moderate Democrat that
politically it makes sense that she
would appeal to many Republicans many
more Republicans than the normal average
Democrat would sort of appeal to I'd
love to get your thoughts on that number
one but number two my analysis has been
effectively speaking for the republican
party's future it doesn't matter that
when you have this number of public
Republicans saying they're voting for
the Democrat whatever the reason is
because it's anti tromper because
Hillary's appealing it's got to be bad
for the republican party's future now
well yes and and to your your initial
premise those two things is it Trump's
failings or Clinton's moderation mean
those things are mutually exclusive I
think both factors are at play here the
bigger question for the Republicans
going forward is assuming Trump loses
which all signs point to and potentially
by a lot uh is it because of Trump the
person or the Trump platform uh there
was the RNC autopsy after mitt romney
lost Mitt Romney ran on self deportation
of immigrants and was caught talking
about you know the forty seven percent
free living off of the American
government that stuff clearly did not
play well and so there's this formal
Republican National Committee autopsy
said we have to reach out to minority
voters in a more robust way we have to
figure out how to do comprehensive
immigration reform we can't get caught
up about voting laws that encourage
early voting we need to get in the early
voting game and try to win those voters
to our side the donald trump nomination
runs in the exact opposite direction of
all that so you could then conclude okay
it's been three times now Obama twice
and now Hilary the problem is not them
the problem is us we need to really do
something dramatically different with
with non-white voters if we're going to
function as a major party in modern
America or and so that's kind of good
Jeb Bush Lindsey Graham Marco Rubio type
of interpretation
their interpretation which more
favorable to Ted Cruz is hey we can
still be at the immigrant really but you
can't have you can sold gold star
mothers while we get the immigrant so
let's not abandon our auntie or good
position we still win as a predominately
all-white party if we we seem to have
the right candidate for it uh I think
that's the debate their problems are
gonna have come to rubber nights a CNN
has done a couple of libertarian town
halls I believe they're going to be
doing a green party town hall we now
have this independent Republican Mormon
who is running an independent campaign
like I said to what extent are are there
let me phrase it a different way are
there any states in which in the big
picture any of these third-party
candidacies could impact election
results uh not as it stands um there is
you look at UM the last couple times
where third-party candidates played a
role uh and I'm sorry to get your
YouTube comments in a lather but Ralph
Nader did contribute to tipping the
election of George W Bush yes the
Supreme Court had played a major role
not also but he had enough votes to tip
on New Hampshire and tip New Hampshire
to Bush and tip Florida to the Supreme
Court uh and a to be a look at 1992 ross
perot it's a myth that he tipped the
whole election to clinton uh there is
evidence that he tipped a georgia ohio
and i want to say New Hampshire free
moving into the third one wrong but they
took those to Clinton but those three in
and of itself were not the Electoral
College margin so you can't say the pro
played that much of a role the
International exit polls bro drew evenly
from Clinton and Bush when people asked
what your what's your second choice I in
those races in the ross perot race pro
had a big number he was seen as a
plausible candidate by some uh in two
thousand nader had a very small number
just the race was so tight that is able
to make make a difference typically
speaking the bigger the lead in
Clinton's case clinton was seen as well
ahead of bush in 92 the bigger the lead
the less of a fee
that people inclined to vote third-party
have to casting that vote they don't
feel that they're going to be a spoiler
so they can safely cast the protest vote
so you may see this year if Clinton is
well ahead of Trump people might say I
feel comfortable voting for jill stein
especially if i'm in a deep blue or deep
red state I feel covering for Gary
Johnson I Trump's a true loser anyway I
don't want that guy to win uh so I don't
mind voting for Gary Johnson so those
numbers may come up because those
factors the counter prevailing force
against that happening is they don't
have a lot of money either one of them
uh and probably not gonna get to the
debate neither one is is getting close
to fifteen percent right now Gary
Johnson's kinda close but I mean he's
more like eight nine ten that's a pretty
big jump to make between now and
mid-september he's gonna do that so
probably not gonna get the facetime
probably not gonna have the money the
one underlying question is is it such a
blow of people say I don't need to have
I dad about just our Gary Johnson to
make me do that vote I was gonna do it
anyway last thing i want to touch on in
it sort of is related to what you're
saying here i am i am having a little
bit of concern that if the polls do stay
uh significantly moderately in in favor
of Hillary Clinton that there may be
clinton voters or would be clinton
voters who would say you know she
doesn't need my vote i'm going to stay
home because she appears to be so far
ahead is that a reasonable concern I
wanted to huge concern there was some of
that 96 where the polls for Clinton doe
were pretty big I think the margin of
being a little smaller because there was
a level of complacency the big risk here
for Democrats is if you have this big
margin against Trump and if you get then
a sizeable vote for Jill Stein uh
because of that it's like an attempt the
election to trump but it could fortify
the green party's position in American
politics if they break five percent
nationally they get a lot of money from
the federal government for 2020 I
estimation is about 10 million dollars
it depends exactly how much the vote is
that determines how much they would get
I would also probably elped on a
state-by-state basis to become Bala
qualify
I have to do a petition a procedure to
get on the ballot next time write in
several states so if you want the green
party to have that kind of foothold then
it makes sense to vote Green Party uh
and not worry whether it's going to be a
spoiler for trouble if you don't want
that to happen if you think it's over a
casual symbolic vote you might want to
ask yourself wait a second do I want to
have the greens in the Democrats face
the next forty-eight years that might
make things a bit touchy going forward
so people should treat them as a serious
mode and think about what do you really
want to have happen after a brief
alright bill scher campaign for
america's future Politico he's watching
it we're watching it thanks as always
bill my pleasure